[Music]
well Kelly Clarkson took Steve Martin
and put him on her new track I hate love
I hate love It's a cruel in mind even
when I know it's bad for me these
memories fill my mind that's the actor
playing the banjo Kelly says the idea to
feature him came to her while writing
the song I referenced Steve Martin in it
and I'm a huge Steve Martin fan because
I'm alive and breathing
and the notebook I
Glide it is
too hard yep I hate love was inspired by
two rom-com films I know everybody's
seen probably the notebook right it's
like a dream
do you want to feed him
yeah and Steve's 2009 film it's
complicated no Jane
it's like one of my favorite movies ever
and it's real life that one is more like
real life not like that they sell you in
The Notebook
the choice would be you want to end up
with a with a handsome Macho actor or a
comedian banjoist
and Kelly she chose the banjoist he said
what
you know it's the right thing
[Music]
I hate love is one of the tracks off of
Kelly's upcoming album chemistry this
album is definitely the Arc of an entire
relationship you know in a whole
relationship
shouldn't be just brought down to one
thing so there's
you know The Good the Bad and the Ugly
kind of thing going on in it the
singer's complicated feelings about love
seem to be stemming from her divorce
from Brandon Blackstock it happens and
that's why there's nothing to hide about
it in that sense
um you know it's just divorce is a
really
thing and Kelly's been no stranger to
sharing her emotions through music I
feel like if you're hiding something
there must be something wrong with it in
March the Grammy winner seemingly shaded
her ex-husband in a round of kalioki on
her daytime talk show Changing lyrics
from Gail's breakout hit
[Music]
to one with Kelly's own personal twist
the backstory well the former couple
reached a settlement in 2022 where Kelly
paid her ex 1.3 million dollars on top
of Child Support I don't know how
anybody I'll just be real with you goes
through grief like divorce any kind of
grief any kind of loss without having an
outlet seems fans will be getting more
of Kelly's story when chemistry drops
June 23rd
nobody
[Music]
I'm your place